[Musique]
bonjour très heureuse d'être parmi vous
ce soir
je suis là pour partager avec vous un
parcours associatif un parcours unique
nous avons pu créer une association
d'enfants en situation de rue d'enfance
tu es en précaire en général
il y a de cela 24 ans c'est un parcours
riche beau de beaucoup d'événements
d'émotions de partage fatigue des fois
mais de bons résultats par après
notre centre a été créé pour justement
aider ses enfants avoir une insertion
familiale c'était tout le début de
travail donc au début c'était un accueil
soit médicaux repas chaud et un travail
acharné pour
insérer ses enfants dans leur famille
d'ailleurs qu'on recevait de 4 ou 5
villes mitoyens El Jadida donc c'est un
travail de 10 femmes actives
l'idée c'était de les aider de le
retrouver un foyer de les héberger mais
surtout de trouver un moyen de les aider
comment
c'était de on avait la possibilité de
rencontrer un Samu social qui rentrait
de France et il a proposé ce service de
volontariat on était très très content
et
alors on a décidé d'aller sur le terrain
et de voir ce qu'on peut faire de faire
une étude justement pour connaître les
conditions qui laissent ces enfants
dehors
quels sont les probabilités de de la
réussite de son insertion où est-ce
qu'il vit sa famille etc donc c'est un
travail avec les éducateurs qu'on avait
presque formé au début mais à notre à
notre façon parce qu'on n'était pas des
professionnels
on a continué cette étude et c'est grâce
à cette étude là qu'on a pu convaincre
la Fondation de France pour ouvrir la
première classe d'éducation non formelle
vous imaginez ils ont accepté de nous
financer une classe en partenariat avec
la délégation de l'enseignement
et alors entre parenthèses j'aimerais
bien vous expliquer ce que c'est que
l'éducation en formelle donc c'est une
plateforme c'est une passerelle pour
aider justement les enfants qui n'ont
jamais été à l'école ou qui ont été à
l'école enfilé l'école une fois qu'il
termine leur année dans notre centre ils
sont pris soit par le cursus normal de
l'État d'enseignement ou quand il valide
la sixième année il part à la formation
on est on les insert à la formation
professionnelle franchement au début
c'était un peu difficile mais par après
c'était une réussite
alors
par après on a eu la petite surprise de
la de l'aide qui nous a été octroyé par
le ArcelorMittal
son acide actuel au Maroc et ben on a pu
ouvrir la deuxième classe d'éducation
non formelle vous imaginez ce que ça
veut dire pour nous encore aider plus et
plus d'enfants possible
donc cette subvention durée pendant 5
ans
là je suis en train de penser à vous
raconter une petite histoire d'une
petite bénévole qui est venue nous
rendre visite au Centre elle voulait
savoir ce qu'on faisait elle voulait
aider à sa façon alors on lui explique
voilà je lui ai pris la peine de
l'expliquer voilà il s'agit de cadre
d'enfants de Cécile voilà des conditions
de famille difficile
des enfants qui fuient parfois leur
foyer etc alors oui elle est repartie
17 20 secondes après elle revient à me
voir s'il te plaît est-ce que tu peux
donner ces 10 dirhams à cet enfant à
Azakia et pourquoi tu veux lui donner
ces 10 dirhams
elle me dit je sais qu'elle m'ont dit
elle est en train de demander et s'il ne
fait elle ne ramène pas les 10 dirhams
sans langue va la grande et je ne veux
pas qu'elle vive ça aujourd'hui je veux
que ça soit un congé pour elle
aujourd'hui mon dieu mon dieu c'est quoi
ces émotions c'est pas possible c'est
une petite fille qui nous donne encore
une petite leçon de volontariat d'aider
alors on a pris les choses en main
encore une fois on s'est dit on va
professionnaliser cette association il
faut faire quelque chose pour ses
enfants là il y a moyen alors on a eu la
chance de contacter des grands
organismes de du travail social et grâce
à cela on a pu
réaliser 5 partenariats cinq
partenariats très importantes c'était
avec l'IRTS donc c'était un institut de
travail social
il nous il nous proposait des stagiaires
qui venaient faire leur stage dans notre
centre entre toi moi à 6 mois et
moyennant une attestation de stage
moyennant
moi j'étais au fait moi j'étais
référente de stage donc on m'a nommé
référent de stage et donc c'était
vraiment un travail magnifique puisque
on avait des échanges entre nous il y
avait la méthodologie nouvelle pour nous
comprenait de chez eux il y avait le
terrain qui était nouveau pour eux et la
culture nouvelle donc c'était un échange
win-win et c'était agréable
autre chose donc il y avait aussi les
phares donc c'est un institut
qui nous qui nous proposait
un échange avec leur enfant sauf que
nous on peut pas ramener nos enfants
là-bas en France mais bon on recevait
huit jeunes oui jeunes qui arrivaient
chaque année et qui faisait des
activités avec nos enfants donc des
activités des contacts des rencontres
des sorties et il se comparer ils
comparer leur situation qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et bien en rentrant chez eux
ils avaient la nette certitude qu'ils
doivent changer de cap ils doivent
changer leur vie d'ailleurs on a donné à
ce projet
le nom de change ta vie c'était ça qui
était merveilleux
d'ailleurs les les responsables nous ont
vraiment félicité pour ça
puis on a eu la visite de 16 jeunes
Français qui ont aménagé deux classes
d'éducation informelle au rurales
c'était très important parce qu'il y
avait nos enfants qui ont aidé nos
membres que je remercie vraiment ils ont
toujours donné des coups de main ils
n'ont jamais été à la réalisation
toujours été à l'avant
là je pensais à vous raconter aussi une
histoire de partage d'une stagiaire qui
était qui était
au centre de la mer qui est venu passer
six mois elle était tellement agréable
qu'elle était bien avec les enfants et
se sentait bien avec eux et ce jour-là
il m'a dit écoute Bouchra moi je
voudrais bien aller
passer le dîner de Ramadan avec avec les
enfants je voudrais bien manger avec eux
ce soir pas de souci elle est partie le
lendemain je devais la rencontrer pour
me donner son son impact
alors elle vient elle rentre elle
commence à pleurer mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe Marion il y a quelque chose qui ne
va pas
non écoute
un enfant qui est venu en courant à la
dernière minute rupture de jeûne et il a
sorti quelque chose de sa poche il a
partagé ça avec moi c'était une sardine
avec les épices marocaines et tout
c'était délicieux mais je te jure mais
je n'arrivais pas à le croire comment
est-ce qu'un enfant qui faisait son
Ramadan la journée et qui partagent
encore avec moi ça c'était fabuleux elle
n'était pas près de l'oublier durant
toute sa vie ça c'est sûr alors pour
convaincre cet enfant à rester dans la
scolarité le fait de le voir tout le
temps au centre tout seul c'était pas la
solution qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire à
votre avis
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire tout
simplement
attirer sa maman et ben c'est ce qu'on a
fait on a créé des ateliers de cuisine
on a créé des ateliers de broderie et
plein plein d'ateliers nous c'était pas
notre spécialité mais c'est la seule
façon d'approcher cette maman d'écouter
ce qu'elle a raconté et même on a appris
la décision de recruter un psychologue
ben oui c'était le plus important à
faire et on a réalisé sur sa proposition
et un petit centre d'écoute et grâce à
ça cette guerrière a peut avoir quelques
armes pour se battre parce que cette vie
regardez cette vie comment comment
est-ce qu'elle l'a vu toute seule face à
un problème comment voulez-vous qu'elle
éduque cet enfant comment voulez-vous
qu'elle fasse donc la seule solution
c'était un peu de de
surélever
ce développement personnel le valoriser
la valoriser elle
2015-2020 c'était une période très
importante pour nous parce que tout ce
qu'on a fait durant ces années ont été
récompensés ont commencé à être
récompensés pendant cette période
comment et ben on a été remarqué par
l'entrée de nationale
on a tellement on a fait du beau travail
quand on nous a proposé
de d'être érigé en organisme de
prévoyance sociale
non seulement cela on a reçu une
subvention
et par la suite on a été reconnu par le
ministère de la Solidarité de la femme
et du Développement social c'était ouf
c'était cool alors dès cette période là
on a pu installer une ingénierie sociale
on rêvé de cela on n'avait pas les les
moyens pour ça mais maintenant ça
commence à se reconstituer on dirait un
puzzle qui commence à se reconstituer
tout simplement
2017 j'arrive à 2017 et ben en 2017
j'aime beaucoup raconter cette partie là
parce que c'est le grand prix on a gagné
un grand prix de la meilleure petite
structure dans le monde arabe
alors sur quoi je vais parler en arabe
liturgie
ça veut dire avec les petits moyens
qu'on avait on a pu faire beaucoup de
choses et valider
par approbation des membres bien sûr de
créer des activités génératrices de
revenus pour justement donner une
autonomie à cette maman à cette maman de
l'enfant
deuxième volet c'était les enfants qui
ont été déjà au centre et qui ont jamais
fait quelque chose de leur vie ils ont
grandi et ben on les a on les a appelés
venez on va vous proposer des agères
pour vous qu'est-ce que vous voulez
qu'est-ce comment vous voulez vous quand
vous êtes ils étaient ravis ils étaient
contents je peux vous dire 40% de ces
projets là ont bien fonctionné et
c'était le c'était pour nous le but là
je passe au résultat allez on a passé
quand même des années dans ce centre
qu'est-ce qu'on a réalisé et ben je peux
vous dire que
5000 enfants on peut être inséré
familialement
est-ce que vous imaginez ce que ça veut
dire ça
500 enfants insérés à le système de
l'éducation non formelle le ffpt donc
l'information professionnelle et le
cursus normal de l'état de
l'enseignement et aussi nous avons 500
enfants qui ont pu être inscrits à
l'état civil il n'avait pas d'état civil
vous imaginez ce que c'est que ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire ça
alors deuxième changement de cap de
notre politique de comportement de la
nouvelle vision de notre centre de LMN
c'était de valoriser de valoriser les
animations
comment
tout simplement par l'insertion au sport
et grâce à ça nos enfants jouent au golf
chaque samedi
8 ans je vous assure donc c'est un sport
que vous connaissez il y a pas grand
monde qui va qui peut exercer ce sport
alors peut-être on veut le banaliser
pourquoi pas on veut
former des coachs de
ce sport pourquoi pas ben oui alors nos
enfants sont dans la nature il joue au
golf et tenez vous bien il y a oui
jeunes cette année qui ont été pris par
l'Académie nationale c'est grand c'est
énorme c'est extraordinaire
aussi je peux vous assurer que les
activités de théâtre musique danse chant
on s'arrête pas
je ne peux pas ne pas parler de du
projet menant projet menace et un projet
avec l'Université de
des lettres et sciences humaines et
la haute école suisse bien sûr avec le
centre de la ML donc ça consiste en quoi
c'est la première fois
ça va se passer cet événement unique
c'est que les docteurs de l'Université
vont s'allier à nos éducateurs à 12
pupilles donc 12 enfants pour travailler
sur le cercle de partage
l'interculturalité et la lecture
l'impact de la lecture sur les cerveaux
sur le sur le comportement de l'enfant
en situation difficile c'était énorme
c'était énorme et grâce à une subvention
qui nous a été accordée par la haute
école suisse et ben on a ouvert une
bibliothèque une bibliothèque
avec un logiciel et cette vidéo et ce
logiciel va permettre à l'emprunt à cet
enfant en situation difficile qui ne
pourra jamais avoir des livres bien sûr
et donc c'était quelque chose d'énorme
je viens presque à la fin pour raconter
que nos jeunes nos enfants ont grandi
sont devenus des jeunes il fallait
penser à les insérer professionnellement
que vous connaissez le resort d'El
Jadida à ouvert une école de
restauration service des étages et
hôtellerie et ben nous jeunes ont été
proposés pour suivre cette formation
ont été proposées pour suivre cette
formation par apprentissage et l'année
dernière 12 Lorient ont eu leur diplôme
avec un grand prix d'un d'un jeune et il
a été même appelé à Qatar Qatar pour le
foot dans
c'était un événement unique et cette
année il y a 16 jeunes qui sont en train
elles sont en cours de formation
j'aimerais bien remercier
j'aimerais bien remercier les
partenaires officiels et leurs officiels
j'aimerais bien les remercier vivement
remercier aussi Lindh grâce à cette
belle plateforme qui a généré beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de mobilité
qui a généré une bonne gouvernance on a
pu réaliser pas mal de projets et
surtout au rural un grand bonjour
aux associations du rural qui font un
travail magnifique
j'ai aussi un remerciement un formuler
pour mes membres de l'association qui
sont toujours là nous nous formons une
bonne équipe
des amis ce sont des amis et quand on
est en amitié on peut réussir beaucoup
de travail beaucoup de choses
je voudrais bien lancer un appel
retraités
les retraités qui sont en congènes qui
peuvent donner et bien vous avez beau
beaucoup de choses à donner au social on
vous attend je lance aussi un appel aux
étudiants aux universités nous avons
beaucoup besoin de vous pour donner des
cours de soutien scolaire à ses enfants
en situation difficile
n'oubliez pas de venir nous voir on vous
attend un grand merci
aux bienfaits grâce à vous
monsieur les bienfaiteurs on a pu faire
des merveilles je vous assure vu que les
peu de moyens même qu'on avait alors on
n'arrêtait pas à vos dons s'il vous
plaît
on est vraiment fier de ce que vous
faites pour le pays un grand merci à
tout le monde
un grand merci à notre grand tutelle
l'entrée de national qui était toujours
à nos côtés
merci je vous remercie de votre
attention à très bientôt